The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this week we are
going to talk about counting.
Tonight is a problem
set eight due.
For this week, we will post
a new problem set tonight
as well.
Counting is very important.
The rest of the semester
after this week,
we will actually explain
probability theory.
And it's all based on counting.
So I'm going to
teach you this week
a whole toolkit of all
kinds of ways how to count.
And as you can see,
we're going to talk
about a lot of different
kinds of rules.
A mapping rule we'll
talk about, the pigeon
hole principle, another
rule, the product rule
and the sum rule.
And these are all ways
to count one thing
by counting another thing.
Actually, what we are
going to talk about
is how to count a
difficult set the objects.
And we will map those
objects to something
that we can count in
a much easier way.
OK.
So let's start with a lot
of definitions actually.
So we have to talk about sets,
sequences, and permutations
to start off with.
So the definition of
a set is as follows.
A set is actually an
unordered collection
of distinct elements.
So as an example,
we may have, say,
a set that contains the
elements a, b, and c.
Well, if you reorder
these elements,
it doesn't really matter.
It's still the same set.
We can also write it
as the set c, a, b.
On the other hand if you
have a collection in which
say the elements
a appears twice,
well, these two
are not distinct.
So this is not a set.
But it is a collection.
And you may call
this a multiset.
But we'll not go into that.
So we will be
talking about sets.
And your interested usually
in the cardinality of a set.
So what's that?
The cardinality or size
is defined as follows.
Cardinality is just
a number of elements
that the set S really has.
So it's a number
of elements in S.
And how do we denote this/ This
is denoted by two vertical bars
around the letter that
represents the set.
So we denote this as follows.
Now, when we talk
about sets, we may also
be interested in ordered
collection of elements.
And that's what we
call a sequence.
So a sequence is
defined as follows.
A sequence is an ordered
collection of elements.
And we also call these
elements components or terms.
And these elements
do not necessarily
have to be distinct-- so
not necessarily distinct.
Now as an example, so
how do we denote this?
For sets, we use this type
of notation like this symbol.
For sequences, we just have a
very simple type of bracket,
just a round bracket.
So an example could be, well,
the elements a, b, and c.
The first entry
or the first term
of the sequence-- depending
on whether you look
at it from the left or
the right, it may differ--
is here a, b, and then c.
Another one could
be a, b, and a.
And as you can see, the element
a occurs twice in the sequence.
So we're going to relate
sets and sequences.
And let's talk about
the permutation.
So a permutation of a set
is defined as follows.
A permutation of a
set S is actually
a sequence that contains every
element in S exactly once.
So every element in S
occurs exactly once.
And as an example, we may
look at the set that we have
described over here,
the set a,b, and c.
And how many
permutations are there?
So the first one I may just
order the elements in a, b,
and c.
So I have, say, the sequence
a and then b, and then c.
There are many more.
I can, for example,
start with b, and then c,
and then may cycle through to a.
That's another permutation
of these three elements.
And I can do this once more.
I can, for example, start with
c, and then a, and then b.
And it turns out that
we can do a few more.
You can also start to c,
and then b, and then a.
We sort of reversed
the order that we
had over here into its opposite,
so first c, then b, then a.
And we can look at
this cycle there.
There's shifts.
And we start with b, a,
and then we rotate through
to c, which is what
we did over here
when you went from this
permutation to this one.
So we have to b, a, and then c.
And then we may start with
a, and we have a, c, and b.
It turns out that
this is actually
all the possible
permutations of this set.
So there's six of these.
And in general, how
many permutations
are there of a
set of n elements?
So let's have a look
here what we did.
So if I want to create
a permutation of a set,
I may start off by selecting for
the first term a, and b, or c.
So I have actually
three choices.
So the first term
has three choices.
The second term over
here, well, for example,
suppose my first term was b.
Then the second
term, well, must be
an element that is different
from b, as yet part of S.
So I have only two choices for
the second term, either c or a.
So the second term
has two choices.
And once I have chosen
the second one, well,
if I've already chosen
b and c, there's
only one element left in
the set over here, only a.
So I have only one choice left.
So in this way, we may count
the total number of permutations
of this set as the
number of choices
that I have for the first term
times the number of choices
for the second term,
3 times 2 times
the number of choices for the
third term, which is only one.
So the third term
has only one choice.
Now in general, we can do
this for any permutation.
And if you want to count
the number of permutations,
of a set with n
elements, well, it
turns out that it's equal to n
times n minus 1 just like here.
We have three elements,
3 times 3 minus 1
and so on, n times n
minus 1 times n minus 2,
et cetera all the way up to one.
And this is n factorial.
And you've seen
this already when
we talked about
Stirling's formula
and how to approximate this.
Now, this type of
reasoning we will
generalize later on when we
come to the Generalized Product
rule.
And But this is
already a first example
of how we go about this.
So permutations relates
sets and sequences.
So now we go on to define
more special functions.
So permutations is
one kind of mapping.
So let's now define functions.
And then we will talk about a
few different flavors of those.
We talk about surjective
functions, injective functions,
and bijective functions.
And the whole idea is is that
if I can use a mapping from one
set to another set
that satisfies some
of those properties,
it can say something
about how their
cardinalities are related.
And that's what we want.
We want to count.
OK So the definition of
a function is as follows.
So a function f from
x to y is actually
a relation between
the sets X and Y.
And we say that--
oh-- with the property
that every single element,
every element, of X
is actually related to
exactly one element of Y.
And we will call x to be the
domain of the function f.
And Y we will call the range
or image of the function f.
So let's give an example.
And to see a couple of
examples of, first of all,
a function and then
relations to that
are actually not functions.
So suppose you have a mapping
from x which just contains
the elements a, b,
and c, just in line
with this example over here.
And we have a mapping f
that maps to the set y.
And the y is just the
numbers 1, 2, and 3.
Well, i could map, for example,
a to 1, b to 3, and c to 3.
Now this is a function.
Because every element of x
is met to exactly one element
of y. a is just mapped to 1.
b is also mapped to
an element, only 3.
c is mapped to 3 as well.
And they usually write this as
f evaluated in a is equal to 1.
And f b is equal to 3.
And f of c is
equal to 3 as well.
Now what is not a
function-- oh, I
could, for example, add another
edge over here if I wanted to.
But this is not a function.
Because b is now mapped
to two elements, 2 and 3.
And that's not what's
covered by this definition.
So this is not a function.
I can also remove, say, an edge.
Well, in this case, b is not
mapped to anything at all.
And that's not a
function either.
So we really have the
property for functions
that there is six exactly
one outgoing arrow,
if you want to think
about it as being a graph,
from each element in x to
exactly one element in y.
So now we can talk
about a few definitions.
So we will talk about these
few properties, surjective,
injective, and bijective.
And then we can start to do
a few interesting examples.
So a function f that goes from
x to y is called surjective.
if every single element of y
is mapped to at least once.
So what does that mean?
To at least once.
So every element of y, so
say 1 for example here,
is mapped to at least once.
Well, to the element
1 we have mapped a.
So that's great.
But for example element 2
is not mapped to at all.
So this particular
example is not surjective.
But we will come to a
few examples that are.
So here we have the distinction
that every element of y,
so every single element of y,
is mapped to at least once.
The injective is defined
in a similar fashion.
But now, every element
of y is not mapped to
at least once, but at most once.
So let's have look over here.
And that's also not true
for this example actually.
Because three is
mapped to two times.
So it's not mapped
to at most once.
So this example is
also not injective.
Because if the
function is injective,
every element of y of the range
is mapped to at most once.
Bijective is if every element
of y is mapped to exactly once.
And we can see that the
function is bijective if
and only if it is both
surjective and injective.
So bijective if and only if
we have both the properties
surjectvie as well as injective.
So let's give a
couple of examples.
So as the first example, we
may have the set x and y.
We have 1, 2, and 3, and set it
to elements a and b over here.
1 is mapped to a, 2 is mapped
to a, and 3 is mapped to b.
And now we can see
that every element in y
is mapped to at least once.
This one is mapped to two times.
This one is mapped to once.
So this one is
actually surjective.
So that's great.
Another example of
something this is injective
is if you have, say, 1, 2,
and 3, and a, b, c, and d.
1 is mapped, say, to a.
2 to b, 3 to d.
Well, in this case we
have that it's injective.
Because every element of y
is mapped to at most once,
once, once, zero
times, and once.
So this one is injective.
And this one is not
injective, right?
Because this one is
mapped to 2 times.
This one is not surjective.
Because this one is
not covered at all.
It's only mapped to once.
OK.
So let us talk again
about permutations.
So let me talk
We can define a mapping
using a permutation that
is an example of a bijection.
So let's do that.
And then we can come
to the mapping rule.
And we can start to
do some counting.
So for example if we have a
permutation, a 1 up to a n, so
let this be a
permutation of the set
S that contains all the
elements a 1, up to a n.
So this is just one
example of a permutation.
And now we may define
the following function.
We say that pi evaluated
in a i give us output i.
Actually, what I mean
here is that if you
take an element in
S, then this one
is mapped to under this
function to i if and only
if a is in the i-th position
in this permutation.
So if and only if today is in
i-th term in the permutation.
So in this case, we know
that pi is bijective.
And why is this?
Well, we know from the
definition of a permutation
that any permutation is a
sequence in which every element
of S occurs exactly once.
So that means that every
position is covered exactly
once by an element of
S. And that is exactly
the definition over
here which says
that every element in the
range is mapped to exactly
once by an element in a domain.
So this is an example
of a bijection.
OK.
So now that we have
defined functions
and the special
properties, let's
talk about the mapping rule,
which we'll do over here.
And now for the
first time we start
to talk about the
cardinalities of sets
and how they're
related to one another.
So the mapping
rule is that first
of all, if f is a
function from x to y
and if f is actually surjective,
well, what do we know?
We actually know
that the cardinality
of the number of
elements in the domain
is at least the number
of elements in the range.
And why is that?
If you look at a
definition of surjectivity,
we know that every
element of y is
covered by some element
in x at least once.
And all the elements in x
and mapped to exactly one
element in y.
So we know that the
cardinality of x is at least y.
Because every element
in y is mapped
by some unique
distinct element in x.
And if a function f is
injective, well, in that case
we know that the
reverse relation holds,
so inequality holds.
The cardinality of x is at
most the cardinality of y.
So why is that?
Well, every element in an
injective function, right?
Every element is mapped
to at most one element.
So every element in y is mapped
by at most one element in x.
So we know that all
the elements in x
are mapped to some element in y.
But every element in y cannot
map to by more than two times
by something in the domain.
So we know that this
inequality holds.
OK.
For a bijective function, we
have that both these properties
hold.
And we will have an
equality over here.
So if this one is bijective,
we have that the cardinalities
are equal to one another.
And this is also called
the bijection rule.
So let's give an
example where we
want to find out how many
ways there are to select
12 doughnuts from 5 varieties.
So let's see how
that would work.
And the whole idea
is that we're going
to define the set that
we want to count, which
is all these possible
configurations of doughnuts
over five varieties of flavors.
And then we're going to map
these to another structure
that we can understand
a little be better.
So let's do this.
So as an example, let x be all
the ways to select, say, 12
doughnuts from 5 varieties.
So let's give an example.
For example, we may
have 2 doughnuts.
And they are in the
chocolate flavored basket.
So we have chocolate.
And suppose we have no doughnuts
in the lemon filled version
of a doughnut.
Suppose he have a whole
bunch of doughnuts,
say 6 of those,
that are with sugar.
We have some that
are glazed, say 2.
And finally, we have just a
couple of plain doughnuts.
So this would be a
configuration that is in x.
Because we have 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, varieties.
And we have 12 doughnuts, 2 over
here, 6 here, 2, and another 2,
12 doughnuts, that are selected
from these 5 varieties.
Now, if you are going to try to
represent such a configuration,
that's usually how we
think about counting,
then we may map this
to a 01 sequence.
So how do we do this?
We can just map the
doughnuts two 0s, the divider
between the two baskets as a 1.
So this is a 1.
Then we have no 0
between these two ones,
because there are no doughnuts
in the lemon filled basket.
So we have one that is the
mapping from this divider
field over here.
We've got 6 0s.
We have another one that
is this divider, two 0s,
two doughnuts in the
glazed version, and so on.
So what do we see here?
We have a 01 sequence where we
have 12 zeros and we have 1, 2,
3, 4 1s.
And we can see that this
mapping is actually bijective.
Because if I have two 0s, I
can map them back to doughnuts.
The 1 I can map back to the
divider between two baskets.
So let y be the set of all
kinds of configurations of 12,
all kinds of sequences.
Oops, maybe I will
not take this one out.
Let's do this one.
So if you are going
to define y as the set
of all 16-bit sequences
with exactly four 1s,
then we know that by
the bijection rule,
we have created this
bijection over here,
that the cardinalities of
x and y are exactly equal.
So now we know that
by the bijection rule,
we have been able to count
the number of elements
in x by counting something else,
which is really how we proceed
in these types of proofs.
So we are now able to just
count these types of objects.
And later on next lecture,
we'll actually figure out
a formula for this one.
So this is an example of how
we can use the bijection rule.
Another example is one in which
we are going to count subsets.
So we'll give a lot of examples
through these two lectures.
And also the problem
set, as you will see,
will have a lot of small
little parts with all kinds
of countings that you will need
to do applying different rules.
So let's talk about how to
count subsets of a set x.
So what we want is a
bijection from subsets
of a set x containing
of, say, 1 up
to n, so the integers 1 up
to n, to n-bit sequences.
We know that we
can do this if you
define a bijection as follows.
So we map a subset
S under a mapping
f to a bit sequence, b1,
b1, all the way to bn.
If I add the
following relation, bi
is computed as either a 1
or a 0, it's computed as a 1
if i is in S. And it's
a 0 if i is not in S.
Now, we know that
this is a bijection.
So if we have a bit
sequence, then we
can construct from this mapping
the corresponding subset.
If you have a subset,
we can use this mapping
to construct the
corresponding bit sequence.
So how many n-bit
sequences are there?
Well, there are 2 to the
power n n-bit sequences.
Why is that?
Well, we have two choices
for b1, a 0 or a 1,
two choices for b2,
0 or a 1, and so on.
So we have 2 times 2
times 2 choices over here.
So we have 2 to the power n
choices for a bit sequence.
So there are 2 to the power
of n number of bit sequences.
And this is actually equal.
Because of this bijection rule
that we have described over
here, this is equal to the
total number of possible ways
to select subsets of x.
So this is the number of
subsets of an n element set.
So this is a very nice
way to demonstrate
how we can use a bijection
rule to count something
that appears to be
much more harder
to think about, to grasp.
At least for me it's
harder to grasp.
So I have a subset
that can be any size
in a set of n elements.
And now I can find
this really easy
going mapping that I
can show to be bijective
and all of a sudden, I
know how to count it.
Because I can just
look at the image
and count those types of
objects, in this case n-bit
sequences.
I get a really
easygoing number that I
can compute fairly easily.
And now I have counted
something much more complex.
So this is how we generally
will think about these things.
OK.
So let's talk now about
the generalized pigeon hole
principal.
So we have covered quite a
lot of definitions right now.
So we explained the
functions mapping rule.
So now we come to generalized
pigeon hole principle
and a few other rules.
OK.
So what about a generalized
pigeon hole principal?
This is actually the
following counting argument.
If I know that the
cardinality of a set x
is more than k times the
cardinality of a set y,
what do I know?
Well, I know that
for all functions f
that have domain
x and range y, I
know that there must exist k
plus 1 different elements of x
that are mapped to
the same element in y.
And if we take a
specific case k=1,
we will actually call this
the pigeon hole principle.
And let me just demonstrate
it by the famous example
of pigeons.
Well, if I have more pigeons
that the number of holes
than they can fly into, I know
for sure there exists a hole
that two pigeons will fit in.
So that's where the
name comes from.
So let me write it out.
So an example is if I
have more than n pigeons,
so the pigeons from the set x,
and say they fly into n holes,
and the holes is my
set y, well, then
I know the cardinality of x is
more than the cardinality of y.
I have more pigeons
than there are holes.
So I know that at
least two pigeons
will fly into the same hole.
So for a generalized
case, how can we
prove something like that?
Well, we could use, for example,
something like a contradiction.
For example, suppose
that for all k plus 1--
as opposed to the
negation is true.
So how do we prove this usually?
So assume we have this.
We want to prove this.
Well, suppose that's not true.
So suppose there's a mapping f.
So a set for all k plus 1
different elements of x,
well, they are not mapped
to the same elements in y.
But what I really know then
is that every element in y
is mapped to at most by
k distinct elements of x.
So that means that the total
number of elements of x
must be at most k times y.
And that's not true.
It's larger by assumption.
So it's a contradiction.
So this is a very
general principle though.
And it's worth
writing it all out.
Because this is a famous rule
that we will use in counting.
And it leads to
interestingly results.
OK.
So let's give another example.
Let's think about Boston.
In Boston, we have say a half
a million non-bald people.
It turns out that there
are at least 3 people that
have the exact same number
or hairs on the head.
So that's kind of weird.
How do we know that?
I cannot point out any three
in Boston that have the same
number of hairs.
I have no idea.
But somehow I can count
and use this principle
and tell you that
it must be true
that in Boston with
500,000 people,
there are 3 of them
that are not bald.
So we exclude the bald people.
Because that would be easy.
They all have 0 hairs.
But say non-bald
people that actually
have the same number of hairs.
So how do we do that?
How can we make such
types of conclusions?
So say Boston has about
500,000 and non-bald people.
And let's call this set x.
Because we're going to use
the pigeon hole principle.
So our claim is that there
exists 3 people in Boston such
that they have the same
number of hairs on their head.
So how do we do this?
Well, we know that
we may generally
assume that any
person has at most
200,000 hairs on their head.
So the number of hairs on
a head is at most 200,000.
So how should I define
my set y in order
to apply this pigeon
hole principle?
So what do we do?
So I want to have
mapping, right,
from all the people the set
x to the number of hairs.
So the number of hairs on one's
head is going to be the set y.
And what do we know?
We know that the cardinality
of y is at most 200,000.
Actually, the way we defined
it it's exactly 200,000.
And the set x has a
cardinality of about 500,000.
So what do we know?
We can apply our generalized
pigeon hole principle.
It's very surprising, because we
notice that x is more than two
times the cardinality of y.
2 times 200,000 is
less than 500,000.
So I know that by this
particular principle,
this particular mapping must
have the property, because this
holds for all mappings, that
there are at least k plus 1, 2
plus 1, 3 different people
in Boston out of the set
x that are mapped to
the same element in y.
That means that they
have the same number
of hairs on their head.
So this is kind of
really surprising.
We can make a statement
without really inspecting
every single person's head.
But we can still make a
statement about the fact
that there are 3 different
people in Boston that have
the exact same number of hairs.
So this is an example of
a non-constructive proof.
And I will give another one.
And it's a very
important principle.
There's actually a new technique
that you haven't seen before.
So far we have been
constructively proofing
all kinds of properties
using induction mainly.
And this is what is called
a non-constructive proof.
Because I cannot give a specific
example that demonstrates that
this claim is true.
But yet, I've shown
that it is true,
but in a non-constructive
way without an example.
OK.
So what about another one?
For example, we may pick 10
arbitrary two-digit numbers.
So pick 10 arbitrary
double-digit numbers.
And we can pick any
sequence of numbers.
I'm just picking a few.
You may add a few, too.
i don't know, 2, 7, 14, I don't
know, 31, 25, 60, 92, and so
on.
So I have 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
I don't know 9, and another one,
say, 91 or something like that.
And so I have 10
double-digit numbers.
It turns out that I can
show to you that there
are two subsets that if I look
at the sum of their elements,
so I look at sum of the
elements of the first subset
and I look at the sum of the
elements of the second subset,
that I can find two subsets
that have an equal sum.
Now if you just look
at those numbers,
and I've now picked 10
arbitrary double-digit numbers,
well, usually it's pretty hard
to figure out whether that's
really true or not.
Maybe I have been selecting
the numbers in such a way
that it's easy to see.
I mean, we can still try
to wrap our minds around it
and try to really solve
this constructively
by giving an example.
It turns out that we can
prove this statement.
And we will use the
pigeon hole principle.
And we do not even have
to actually-- oh, you
have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, sure.
We can make it double-digits.
So I could put this here.
It'll be 4, 2 of I want to.
But yeah, just select
something else.
It doesn't really matter.
Yeah.
So what we are going to show now
is that through the pigeon hole
principle, we can prove that
there are two subsets that
have the same sum.
And just by inspection it's
a very hard problem to solve.
So I did not even
give you an example.
But we can still show this.
So how can we go
ahead with this?
So let's think together
about this problem.
So I want to choose
two sets x and y.
And somehow, I want to
have a mapping, right,
from any double-digit
set of numbers.
Somehow I want to
map that to sums.
Because that's what
I'm interested in.
I'm interested in sums.
And I want to show
something about subsets
of these double-digit numbers.
So what do I do?
I take x as the collection
of subsets of these numbers.
And I want to that there are
at least two subsets that
map to the same sum.
So let's first count
how many we have here.
We already did this.
We made a mapping from subsets
to two binary sequences,
bit sequences.
In this case, we
have 10 numbers.
So we have 2 to the power
10 possible subsets.
So this is equal to 1,024.
Now y is going to be
the sum of a subset.
So what do I know?
I know that the
possible sums range
from 0 all the way to,
well, what's the maximum?
sum that I can have
out of a subset of 10
double-digit numbers?
So I can select all the
10 elements in this set.
And they are double digit.
So at most, they are 99.
So I know that
this set is really
the set of all possible sums.
Now we know that 1,024
is more than 990.
So the cardinality of x is
more than the cardinality of y.
So by the pigeon
hole principle, we
know that there exists at least
two different elements of x.
In our case, there exists
two different subsets
that map to the same
elements in y, the same sum.
So now we have shown that
even though we have not
shown any particular
example that demonstrates
this claim that there are
two different subsets that
have the same sum, we
still got a proof using
counting that this is true.
So this is called a
non-constructive proof.
Let me write it down.
And this is a great way
of proofing properties.
So now we can continue
with another definition
where we look at
another property.
Over here, we talks about
surjectivity, injectivity,
and bijectivity.
And now we will talk about
the following property.
We say that a k
to 1 function is f
from x to y actually maps
actually k elements of x
to every element of y.
So what do we know?
Well, we can have the
following counting rule
that we call the division rule.
And it says that if f
such a type of function,
so if f is k to 1,
well then we know
that the cardinality
of the domain
is equal to k times
the cardinality y.
And why is that?
Well, exactly k elements of
x map to each element of y.
So the first element
of y, we have
k elements of x mapped to it.
The second element of y, k
elements mapped to that one.
So we know that the
domain is exactly
k times the range, k times
the size of the range.
Now this division rule
actually generalizes
the bijection rule,
which I've put
over there, the bijection rule.
And why is that?
Well, that's because a function
is a bijection if and only
if it is actually 1 to 1.
So if you replace k by 1, we
have that exactly one element
of x is mapped to
every element in y.
And that's the definition
of a bijection.
And the bijection rule says
that if you have a bijection,
then the cardinality
of the domain
is equal to the cardinality
of the range, so for k
equals 1 here.
So let's give an example
on how this works.
I think we can take
this out actually.
So let's give an example
using a chessboard,
where we have 2 identical rooks
and we want to count the number
of ways we can put them on the
chessboard in such a way that
the 2 rooks cannot
see one another,
meaning that the rooks are on
different rows and on different
columns.
So let's give an example.
So the example is like this.
So how many ways do we have
to place 2 identical rooks
on a chessboard in such a
way that no row or column
is shared?
So how can we do this?
Well, for example, let's
look at a chessboard.
And suppose we have a rook
over here and a rook over here.
And say the first rook is
on row 1 and on column 1.
And the second rook is
on row 2, R2, on row R2,
and on the column
that is indexed by C2.
So how can we describe
such configurations?
Well, I could describe this
by using a sequence in which I
look at the placement
of the first rook,
and then describe the
placement of the second rook.
So I may have r1, c1,
and then r2 and c2.
So this could be
a way to describe
the positioning of these rooks.
And I could create a mapping
f that is doing this for me.
And so if I call this
an example of a valid.
So let y be the set of
valid rook configuration.
And this is one example of it.
So this is part of this set.
And if I define x
as all the sequences
r1, c1, r2, and c2 such that,
well, the rook over here
does not share a row
with the rook that
is described by this position.
So r1 is not equal to r2.
And they also do
not share a column.
So the first rook has column c1.
The second one is on column c2.
So also c1 and c2
should be different.
So these sequences are
really placements, right?
So this describes rook 1.
This describes the rook 2.
And the whole combination
is really a placement.
So now I have
described the function
f that maps a sequence
that describes
the position of the first
and the second rook,
maps such a sequence
to an element in y,
which is a valid
rook configuration.
So now let's have a look at how
we can apply the division rule.
So is this function bijective?
Is that true?
So is it true that every--
so I have a mapping that
goes from here to here.
But is it true that every
valid rook configuration
is mapped to exactly once?
Is that true?
Is this the only sequence that
will map using this function f
into a valid configuration?
Yup.
It's true.
So you can switch
rook 1 and rook 2.
And it will still look the same.
The 2 rooks are identical.
They look exactly the same.
So we have, again, the
exact same configuration.
And we can see that this
particular sequence also
maps to the same.
It just swap the positions.
So we have r2, c2,
r1, and c1 also maps
under f to the
same configuration.
And those are the
exact 2 possibilities
that can happen that map
to this configuration.
Every valid configuration is
mapped to exactly 2 times.
So now we can use
the division rule.
Because f is 2 to 1.
So f is 2 to 1.
What does that mean if you
apply the division rule?
It means that the cardinality
of all those sequences
is equal to 2 times
the cardinality
of valid configurations.
Or in other words,
the cardinality
for all the valid configurations
is the cardinality
of all those possible
sequences divided by 2.
So now we can start
counting x over here.
So how do we do that?
Well, I'm going to use something
similar as what we did when
we were counting permutations.
And we'll generalize
it in a moment.
So how do we go about this?
Well, let's have a look.
If I have r1, c1, and r2, and
c2, so this is a sequence.
So how many choices do I have?
Well, a chessboard has 8 rows.
So I can choose 8 possible
rows for the first rook.
It also has 8 columns.
So I have 8 possible
choices for the column.
But what about the second rook?
Well, the second rook can
be on any row except the one
that I've already
selected for the first.
So this 8 minus 1, we have
7 possible choices to select
the row for the second rook.
It must be different from the
one that was already selected.
And I have 7 possible choices.
And similarly for
this particular column
as well, the column
has to be different.
So how many choices do I have?
Well, it's not 8.
It's one less, because
I've already selected
the one for the first rook.
So I have 7 choices.
So the cardinality of x is
actually equal to 8 times
8 times 7 times 7.
So it's 8 times 7
squared divided by 2.
So now we have to counted,
by using the division rule,
we have to the divide this by 2.
We have counted the total
number of valid configurations.
So now we are going to
generalize this principle
that we have talked about here.
And we will do that
over here I think.
Yup.
And that's the
generalized product rule.
So the generalized product
rule is as follows.
It's essentially
saying that if we
have a set of sequences
of length k, then
how can we count those?
Well, if we know the
following properties-- well,
let me first write out
the generalized product
rule is as follows.
Let S be a set of
length k sequences.
Then I know that if there
are n1 possible first entries
and if I know that once I've
selected my first entry,
there are n2 possible second
entries for each first entry.
And if I continue
like this, my choice
for the third term
in the sequence
is I've always n3
possible choices
given my selection for
the first 2 entries.
So if I have that property
that continues in that way,
so let me write it out.
So we have n3
possible third entries
for each combination
in this case of first
together with second entries.
And if I continue this
all the way to nk,
so nk possible kth entries
for each combination of all
the previous
entries, then I know
that the set S
can be counted as,
well, I've n1 possible
choices for the first entry.
Once I've chosen
to fix that one,
I have n2 possible choices
for the second, then
n3 possible choice
for the third.
And I go all the way to nk.
Well, let's first talk about
it from the perspective
of the chess problem here.
I got 8 possible choices for r1.
Given r1, I don't care.
I still have 8 possible
choices for the column here.
So I have 8 choices here.
But for the third one, once
I have selected r1 and c1,
I only have 7 choices left for
r2 and 7 choices left for c2.
So that's an
example where we use
this particular
generalized product rule.
Also when we were counting
the number of permutations,
we were saying we can
fix the first entry
of a permutation
in n ways if I have
a permutation for n elements.
And then I have the second
entry, the second term,
of a permutation has
only n minus 1 choices.
Because I've already chosen one.
And the next one has
n minus 3 choices.
Because I've already
selected 2 of them.
So I have only n
minus 2 choices left.
Then I have n minus 3 choices.
Because I've already
selected 3 and so on.
And I get n factorial.
So that's the same kind of
principle that we have here.
So let me give an example where
we can see how this works.
So what do we do?
In this example, we want to
count the number of committees.
So it's the exact
same kind of principle
that we are going to talk about.
So we are going to count the
number of communities described
by sequence x, y, z, where
x the first one is, say,
the leader of the committee.
The second one
indicates the secretary.
The third one is
some consultant.
So they're all different.
They have all different roles.
And such a committee is
elected from n members.
And in how many
ways can I do this?
Well, I have n ways to choose
my first term in the sequence.
I have n ways to
choose the leader.
So there's n ways to choose x.
How many ways do I
have to choose y?
Well, if I've chosen
already a leader,
I need to choose someone else.
So I have n minus 1 members
left, n minus 1 ways
to choose y.
I'm just not
allowed to choose x.
And then I will
have n minus 2 ways
to choose a z except x and y.
And so for each x, I have only
n minus 1 ways to choose y.
For each x and y, I have only
n minus 2 ways to choose z.
So if I multiply
all this together,
I get n times n minus
1 times n minus 2
to choose all these
committee-- this
is the total number
of possible committees
that I can select from an
n member set of people.
So let's go to a little bit
of a different example that
uses the same principle.
OK.
Let's make some space.
In the second problem,
I will define to you
a defective dollar bill.
It's not really defective.
But it's a property that we
will assign to dollar bill.
And you can check for
yourself whether you
have one in your wallet.
So let's define a
defective dollar bill
to have the property
that if you look
at the 8-bit serial
number, some of the digits
appear more than once.
So some digit appears
more than once
in the 8-bit serial number.
So you can check our own wallet
and check for your $1 bills
and check whether you
have a defective dollar.
This seems to be a pretty
specific and rare property,
right?
Well, check you dollar bills.
You'll figure out that you have
probably a defective dollar
bill in your wallet.
So that's kind of weird.
But it seems this property.
If you look at
that, it seems to be
something that is
maybe a little bit more
common than we thought it is.
It seems to be so special.
So let's do a counting
argument and find out
what's happening here.
So let's look at a fraction
of the non-defective.
So we are counting the opposite,
the non-defective bills.
Well, that's the number of
non-defective serial numbers
divided by the total
number of serial numbers.
And let's call these small
x and y and count these.
So let's see.
So first of all, let's count y.
Well, that's easy, I have 8
digits in my serial number.
So I have 10 choices
for the first digit,
10 choices for the
second one, and so on.
In total, I have
10 times 10 times
10 to the power 8 choices.
What about x?
Well, I'm using, again,
our generalized product
rule over here.
Well, if I'm going to have
a non-defective dollar bill,
then all the digits in
the 8 digit serial number
have to be different.
So for the first digit,
I have 10 choices.
Now that I've selected
my first digit,
I have 9 digits for my second
choice for my second digit
in the serial number.
Then I have 8
possible choices, 7,
because I've already selected 3.
And I cannot choose
those anymore--
times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3.
And now I have chosen an 8
digit serial number in which
all the digits are different.
OK So how many are these?
Well, this is actually
equal to 10 factorial
divided by 2 factorial.
And it turns out to be
something like 1,814,400.
possible choices.
So now let's look
at the fraction.
It turns out if you
divide this by this,
you get a really
very small fraction.
This is actually
equal to 1.8144%
So a very small fraction
is non-defective.
So almost all the dollars
are sort of defective.
It simply means that they
have this special property
that some digit
occurs more than once.
So it's kind of interesting.
So we can already
see that by counting,
it's sometimes a little
bit counterintuitive.
Because if I would see
this particular property,
I would in first
instance think that it's
a very special property.
But that's not true.
It's very common it turns out.
Now a special case of the
generalized product rule
is the product rule.
And this is defined as follows.
We are going to first of all
define a product over sets.
The definition is
that the product
of a set A1 with A2
up to An is actually
equal to the set of sequences.
So the first entry is
selected from the first set,
the second entry is selected
from the second set, and so on.
And now the product
rule tells us
by just applying that
reasoning over here
that the cardinality of the
product of all those sets
is actually equal to the
cardinality of the first set
multiplied by the
cardinality of the second set
and so on up to the
cardinality of the last set.
Because we have this
number of choices
for the very first
element over here,
this number of choices for
the second one, and so on.
And we apply that rule, and we
see that this is the result.
Now when we use this, in
specific to count all the n-bit
sequences, we have exactly
2 choices for the first bit.
We have to set 0,1 in our
example times the set 0, 1 over
here and so on.
And that's how we derived that
we have 2 times 2, 2 the power
n choices for an n-bit sequence.
So now we come to the sum rule.
And we will give an
example for that.
So the sum rule states
that if you look at sets,
then we may be able
to count their union.
And we will consider
a very specific case.
In the next lecture, we will
talk about the general case.
So the sum rule is the
following counting mechanism.
If the sets A1 up to
An are all disjoint,
so they are disjoint
sets, then we
know that if I try to count
the union of all those set,
it's going to be the sum of
the separate cardinalities.
So let me just write
it out actually.
So it's the cardinality of
A1 plus A2 all the way to An.
Why is this?
Well, all the sets are disjoint.
So there are no
intersections between sets
that contain elements.
All the intersections are empty.
So counting the union is really
counting each separate set.
And that's why we have the sum.
And in the next lecture, we
will talk about inclusion,
exclusion rule.
And then we will
take into account
that we have intersections
that are not empty.
But let's give now
an example where
we count the number of passwords
with certain properties.
And we will apply all these
different rules together.
And that's the type
of problems that you
would like to be able to solve.
So in our last example
here, we have that passwords
have the following property.
They are 6 to 8 symbols.
So that's property 1.
We have that the
very first symbol
must be special in the
sense that it is a letter.
And this can an
upper or lowercase.
And say that the other symbols
are actually letters or digits.
So let's count the total
number of possible passwords.
We're going to use the sum rule.
So let's define
what kinds of sets
we are taking the symbols from.
So the first set is
for the first symbol,
which we call f or first.
We have all the letters
a, b, c in lowercase,
and then all of
them in uppercase.
And in total, we have
52 elements in this set.
For the second symbol,
or the other symbols,
we have all these
letters, but also
all the digits, 0, 1, up to 9.
And this set actually
has cardinality 62.
We added 10 digits.
So let's talk
about-- actually, we
like to use this in
the sum rule as well.
So how do we count?
What kind of possibilities
do we really have?
So let's describe
the set of passwords
explicitly in a formula.
So let p be the set
of possible passwords.
And this one is actually
equal to-- well,
I need to choose a first symbol.
And then I need to choose a
second symbol, and a third,
and a fourth, and a
fifth, and a sixth.
That's one possibility.
I use 6 symbols.
I can also use 7 or 8 symbols.
But this is one of them.
We also denote this
as S to the power 5.
That's an equivalent notation.
The other possibilities
for passwords
are that we first choose
an entry from f, a letter.
And then we will need to
choose another 6 symbols.
In total, we have 7.
And we have another possibility
where we choose a first symbol,
and then we choose
7 other symbols.
So has 8 symbols.
This has in total 7.
This one has in total 6 symbols.
So this covers all the
possible passwords.
So let's count them.
We know that these sets
are all the different.
They are distinct.
These are sequences that have
6 entries, 7, and 8 entries.
So if you look at
the cardinality of P,
it's actually equal to
the sum by the sum rule
that we just
described over there,
is equal to the very first
one, f times S to the power
5 plus the cardinality
of the product
of f with S to the power 6.
And we have f times
S to the power 7.
So this is simply by
application of the sum rule.
And now we can apply
the product rule
very simply, which is this one.
So that's equal
to the cardinality
of f times the cardinality
of S to the power 5.
And then we have the same
rule applied to this one.
It's the commonality of
f times the cardinality
of S to the power 6.
And then we have the cardinality
of f times the cardinality of S
to the power 7.
Now, we simply
plug-in these numbers.
And then you will have the
total number of passwords
that you can select from.
It turns out to be about 1.8
times 10 to the power 14.
So here we have applied both to
sum rule and the product rule.
So in general, you
will see that you
have to apply multiple
rules together
in order to find an answer
to your counting problem.
And you'll see that
on a problem set.
And we will give a few more
examples in next lecture.
And we will start talking about
the generalization of the sum
room called inclusion exclusion.
And we will give you another
type of proof technique called
combinatorial proofs.
All right.
Good luck with the problems.